[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quad Riga coming to you from the heart
of the German capital Berlin now until
recently Germany had a reputation for
being a country that welcomed refugees
and asylum seekers with open arms but
with a hugely important national
election coming up in September the mood
is changing of course
tens of thousands of people from places
tormented by war and persecution such as
countries across Africa as well as Syria
and Afghanistan are still risking their
lives in desperate attempts to make
their way to Europe but after welcoming
so many refugees into the country
Germany is now sending a growing number
of them back to their countries of
origin so here today on quadriga the
topic we're discussing is getting tough
Merkel's Asylum u-turn question mark and
to do so I'm joined here in the studio
by three seasoned observers and analysts
let me introduce them to you beginning
with Alan Posner who is a political
commentator for the Berlin Daily devote
he argues that welcoming migrants while
punishing Greeks and other southern
Europeans has helped to deconstruct the
European Union let's hope he says it's
not too late to change course also with
us is male East older political analysts
from Afghanistan who says deporting
Afghans may be ethically problematic
because of the ongoing war in
Afghanistan but it's the only way for
Angela Merkel to fend off the challenge
from Germany's populist right and the
warm welcome to goes through an tear
Bauer a well-traveled journalist who
focuses on the Middle East and
Afghanistan and and she says by
deporting people to the war zone that is
Afghanistan Germany is betraying its
human rights principles it's a
fascinating a very important topic we've
got to discuss today Alan I'd like to
give you the first question
critics of Angela Merkel are saying that
Germany is becoming a country that once
was a had a welcoming culture but now
has a culture of deportation
do you agree no not at all I don't look
at with the first part Germany never had
a welcoming country culture our
Constitution the Dublin laws of the
European Union
actually stipulated we don't take any
refugees because if they come from third
countries which are deemed safe as are
all the countries around us where these
refugees would have to pass through we
should send them back that's in our
Constitution I'm gonna marker made a an
exception two years ago to this inhuman
or inhumane rule letting in hundreds of
thousands because the whole system was
blowing up in all of our faces but
Germany was unprepared for that what
we're now doing is gearing up to deal
with the fact that after the hundreds of
thousands who we let in at least fifty
percent if not more have no right to be
here so we have to you know do you send
them back to make room for those who do
have a legitimate reason to be here so
that this whole idea of we want such a
welcoming country and now we're doing a
u-turn is totally wrong we were never a
welcoming country there was a short
burst of so-called welcomed culture in
2015 and now we're getting back to more
or less normal about what do you say
I agree partially there was there was a
big burst and the question was what
happened afterwards because I think
there was a sort of u-turn because there
was a u-turn in the politics of Angela
magic because she said okay we can do it
and then she saw that it's more
difficult actually than she imagined
also because she didn't consult it with
the European partners and we were the
only one to take off more or less but I
think the question about talking there
about the welcoming culture is not only
talking about politics it's also talking
about society and I don't see that
really the German society which has
broadly welcomed the refugees has
completely changed I don't see that I
see in the media we are talking a lot
about the far-right who are against the
migrants or the refugees but I think
there's still a lot of initiatives who
are trying to help the refugees to feel
better to integrate to learn German and
this is part of the welcoming culture
the other is more welcoming politics for
me
I think you have to look at the
structure of the society to
sociologically speaking Germany is a
country that is from the religious point
of view not from the culture point of
view the unit of cooperation in the
society is not only family it's the
whole society even helping the southern
Europeans was it was because miracles
felt not only America but Germany
generally felt that they had to help
their fellow human beings when it comes
to the welcome and culture of Germany I
always criticized the non Germans who
have lived here for a long time and some
of them have also come new they lack the
initiative to be honest I see a lot of
my German friends who have taken a lot
of initiatives they volunteer to work
with with the newly arrived refugees but
the non Germans a lot of the Turkish
Arabs and also we have the biggest
Afghan community in Europe in Germany
literally they only criticize the system
they only criticize the new people of
comment they criticize the intervention
of the international community in my
country but what have you done for the
refugees it's a huge question it's
interesting we you're talking about your
own home country Afghanistan one reason
why the story we're talking about today
is so much in the headlines is because
there have been deportations of people
from Afghanistan back to your country of
origin back to their country of origin
which is a war zone why are they being
deported to a war zone I think you have
to desegregate the whole situation there
it is a war zone I mean if you look at
it from the economic point of view like
also University says that if there are
1000 battle related deaths in a country
then it's a war it's a civil war whereas
our president he described it as a
regional war and a global war on
terrorism there so there is war there
are pockets like in Kunduz a few people
come from Condors I understand they have
a legitimate reason people come from
Helmand ants and they have a legitimate
reason that there's so many places in
that country that also enjoy a lot of
perks of the international intervention
at the same time the state has done
really well to provide for them so it
depends who you're sending back at the
same time it's so difficult to see who's
the has a legitimate claim to stay here
who
doesn't have it a lot of Africans have
also come from countries that fax and
especially Iran to who they lived there
for 40 years they face a lot of
discrimination horrible horrible
situation that they face that they've
come here to so it's a very complex
phenomenon for now well I think it's a
to get a little bit of background to
what we're talking about here we need to
talk about the alternative for Germany
party here in which could emerge it's an
anti-islam anti-immigrant I immigrant
party that could become the third
political force in German politics at
the September elections Angela Merkel
has reacted with a hard line on
deportation and Refugee policies in
general let's just get that background
before we continue the discussion in
late summer 2015
Germany opened its heart and its borders
Chancellor Angela Merkel was touched by
the suffering of refugees and she
allowed hundreds of thousands of them to
enter the country but now things have
changed the open-door policy has been
revised last year 80,000 people whose
applications for asylum had been turned
down were sent back home that's a record
number the federal and state governments
recently adopted measures aimed at
speeding up deportations there's even a
controversial plan the house failed
asylum seekers in special facilities
near airports so they can't escape
[Music]
and the authorities may be allowed to
search refugees smartphones to confirm
their identities will Angela miracle now
become known as the deportation
Chancellor will Angela Merkel Alan
Posner beaker be known as the
deportation Chancellor is she with the
election coming up in September is she
pandering to the far-right to the
populace right here in Germany a lot of
people save this that's what's happening
look it's not pandering to the populace
right if you take laws seriously German
law says that an international law by
the way which applies here the Geneva
Convention on refugees say that you have
a right to be considered a refugee if
you have been persecuted for political
religious or other reasons not just
anyone who comes here because in their
country there's a war on or because
they're economically in dire straits so
we go to great lengths in Germany to
find out it takes a long time an
individually process that's why it takes
so long to find out who has a legitimate
right to stay and who doesn't and it's
about I mean with people from the
Western Balkans
for instance Serbia Kosovo Albania who
are the second biggest group 98% I have
their have their applications turned
down so it's simply implementing the law
to send them back and you can go through
country by country where as for instance
among Syrian refugees I think something
like six ninety six percent are accepted
and can settle here and and have their
applications accepted so enforcing the
law isn't becoming a deportation chance
that it's finally doing what should have
been done actually two years ago but the
question of the law is very much up to
interpretation so I agree that what
Angela Mary did in 2015 that was against
the Franchi laws which were unjust as
you said yourself I never understood why
Greek and Italy agreed to that that they
would accept all those who come because
we are
so much in the middle of everything they
there's no way to come if you don't come
by plane and that's already difficult
you know enough so the question is what
what what is really the criteria which
you apply so you say okay they adopt the
criteria for Syrians to stay here for
because there's a war isn't there a war
in Afghanistan that's a question I think
there's no warrant Serbia that's clear
so I think it's clear we they have to be
brought back because we cannot take
everybody who wants just to come here
but if we if we ask the Eastern European
refugees to go back that's one thing for
me to to deport Afghans to Afghanistan
is another thing you say okay they are
safe safe places I doubt that those who
go back and they have people have been
people for example who have been brought
back who are part of our religious
minority I doubt that they have a
possibility to develop myself themselves
and I think we should at least accept
all those who come really from countries
like Iraq like Afghanistan like Syria
like Eritrea well you have no safety and
our German as Asylum laws say that they
don't ask for everybody that he has to
show that he has been personally and
individually pursued well they I think
you're wrong the Geneva Convention if
you have signed actually states that as
a refugee you have to prove that you
have been persecuted for your political
yeah okay and and and and for instance
someone who comes who for instance
someone who comes from Morocco and says
I'm a homosexual and this society is not
welcoming the ruling of German courts is
no society is not welcoming to
homosexuals in in in in in Morocco but
if you don't flaunt it you can live your
life if you're a closeted homosexual you
can live your life and they are sent
back I know this because a friend of
mine his boyfriend was sent back I think
this is difficult but given the fact
that so many people are really in danger
of life and limb in Syria for instance
and in parts of Iraq
this is you know this is what you have
to do and other circumstances I might
you know say well this is really hard to
send back someone to Morocco
who's the homosexual who might get
stoned if they people found it out but
you know there's only so many resources
well this is the idealist verses that is
versus the realist discussion very
classic
the problem is would situation
Afghanistan we got more close to half a
million refugees back from Pakistan they
were forcibly removed from Pakistan so
the level of racism you see there and
the kind of deportations that are taking
place there and then you compare it with
Merkel II can't really call her there
deportations the Chancellor it's unfair
to help at the same time these if you
use actually contributed to by the to
the Pakistani society they and of course
they don't have the kind of social
system that exists in in Afghan in in
Germany that could have helped them so
for me I'd never said their their safe
places in Afghanistan but if you take
them the units of comparison would be
looking at the path of the country and
then comparing the country with
countries like Syria in Iraq and so on
and so forth
and there in the past we've never had
the kind of situation we have the kind
of open society that you have today the
progress that has been made today and
then competitive with Syria we don't
have that level of violence we don't
have that kind of brutality that is
perpetrated both by the state now so
there's a lot of non-state actors and
the state in Afghanistan is actively
trying to address the issues of asylum
seekers in Europe at the same time
there's a national program they're
working on for reintegrating the
refugees that are coming from the region
countries like Pakistan so the state is
actively trying to actively trying to
address the question but it is
challenging you could be a potential
target of an attack you could lose your
limbs you could lose your life
it could happen the likelihood is much
higher than Germany but I again it's a
matter of priorities for states like how
many people can Germany take and how
many people it can take from Syria or
Afghans and so forth so you don't want
to and for politicians it's a cold
business it's not only about transfers
it's also about making sure that they
stay in power if they're all in power
our gain
power and if they see that if the
society does not agree with them I've
worked with politicians it's going to be
a different game politics I agree the
question is how do you define the
country it's politics like the question
do you say that their own sexual from
Morocco
is he really in danger or not that's
politics this was a political decision
and I think for example in this I agree
with angular marking from 2015 that we
can take in more and that we have to
send back those who are very obviously
have no no reason to stay here like
Eastern European like those from not are
not African who have no individual
reason then you you I mean I would love
for all that comes to say here because
that would the capacity that would be
developed here after some years they
would go back or at least they would
develop those links and my country would
be helped with this but is it
politically possible for her that she
would stay in power I mean the challenge
is enormous for her and I think that's
the question also of accompaniment by
the civil society and by the media I
think for example that too much coverage
has been given media coverage has been
given to the far-right when you have a
demonstration of 20 people of the
alternative for Germany you have a big
thing in the newspapers I think that's
not necessary I think what has been
neglected since 2015
are these all these initiatives which
are still working with refugees and for
refugees so I think we get an image of a
society which is not not corresponding
to the reality but there's a translate
into votes are we going to face the same
kind of situation that we have in the
u.s. right now because everybody thought
it no what I wanted to see you create
somehow reality if you talk only about a
certain thing it looks bigger than it is
yeah but we know that the far right not
only in Germany but all across here
because they're the the receiving end of
a lot of criticism and a lot of bullying
okay anyhow and what they've really
mastered is the narrative too that
resonates with the sentiments of people
so
could we create another narrative and do
we have destructors in the site in
politics to counter that narrative and
that's exactly what happened yes no one
had that narrative I mean Bernie Sanders
had it but he was a young boy by the
very forces that are very progressive
malaise I'd like to go back to a
PowerPoint you at home what you were
talking about people like people who
have applied Afghan citizens who have
applied for asylum here in Germany and
who have had their applications turned
down have been sent back to Afghanistan
I just want to look at a case in point a
young man called Kazim before we talk
about that just a little bit more Qasim
has now returned to a country that he no
longer considers home he doesn't
understand why he was not allowed to
stay in Germany he was working to build
a new life there I was in Germany for
six years in the state of Bavaria I
lived and worked in Augsburg and I
learned the German language my life was
secure there mine 11 many leave Nevada
high notes
Cosima's staying with friends in the
northern Afghan city of mazar-e-sharif
Taliban forces are active in the region
last November for civilians were killed
in a truck bomb attack on the German
Consulate in Mazzone Kasim can't go back
to his home village because it's
controlled by the Taliban deportations
to Afghanistan are they a violation of
Human Rights
[Music]
how much do you feel for Cathy a lot
it's sad it's really sad not only
because the the country is unsafe but
also because he spent six years of his
life here I mean could have been a
potentially a great person not only for
Afghan service for Germany yeah these
young people they have the capacity they
have the potential to to be productive
in the society no doubt about it
but at the same time again politics is a
cold business you know it's not all that
fuzzy Allen should calcium be in Germany
or in Afghanistan it's uh you know in an
ideal world I suppose he'd be here but
if that's where he wants to be I don't
see why someone should complain about
having spent six years in Germany learnt
German which is an asset in in
Afghanistan learnt trade which is an
asset for him you know I mean goodness
refugees from Nazi Germany who then
returned to dead to Germany after the
war they didn't complain that they had
spent six years somewhere else and had
to learn English if with her then South
Africa Australia United States or
wherever in France it seems a bit
strange that instead of saying wow I was
a guest of Germany for six years I was
given a good education I was able to
educate myself now I come back instead
it instead of which he's complaining he
may have good reason but you know there
is this other side that he had you know
they had to have your opportunities here
mmm
the difference says he goes back to a
war zone he doesn't come back to a
Germany there where there was no war
again and at the same time these two
countries are so different that
situation was very different from this
situation and come back to Germany and
forty-five everything's in ruins you
know I mean come on well look we don't
know we don't know about cuz him he
obviously doesn't want to be where he is
I can understand that but on the other
hand it is it is the law you can be
unjust the law Oliver had a law there
Nazis had laws no it's okay it's a law
of international law which 146 nations
have put into place the Geneva
Convention
this isn't even binding what is finding
for us are there are certain laws which
are interestingly broader than the
Geneva Convention and the states have
the final say on every single case I
mean again it's not easy for Germany we
understand but Germany will have a
population deficit these people could be
extremely helpful in the future for this
country I know the Syrians who have come
there the cream of the society a lot of
them are highly educated they could
contribute in many ways and also these
young Afghans could contribute in many
ways to the German society and
especially if you waste somebody's six
years of his that he said he's gained
capacity but at the same time you say
German languages is maybe something that
he can use in Afghanistan you never know
you know the economy has gone so bad
after the one in 50,000 soldiers because
it was created around the services
provides these soldiers who went out so
maybe he doesn't even have a decent
source of income so for him it was a
totally different story I'd like to
begin to wrap it up by just getting to
the core of the issue that we've been
talking about today Germany took in a
lot of people more than more than a
million people that's for sure and it is
now beginning the process of sending
back people to their countries of origin
maybe hundreds of thousands of people a
quick answer from each of you but I
would really like to know how does
Germany avoid becoming a hard-hearted
country in the midst of this process it
avoids becoming a hard-hearted country
by sticking to the letter of the law and
sending back people who don't have the
right to be here and welcoming those who
do have the right now the law is
hard-hearted if you will but obeying the
law doing what the lords dress is surely
what a law-abiding what the rule of law
demands so that's what it's about
I think law is up to interpretation I
think how hard it would be to bring them
all back to have districtís into an
interpretation of the law for me the the
good solution would be that those who
come from conflic countries have the
right to stay here crisis war countries
and those who come for strictly economic
reasons should be turned back if they
cannot
prove that they have individual reasons
to stay I think the best solution is
take more time to study the phenomenon
more in depth to see its economic
political cultural implications because
for now there's so much of confusion
whether the refugees are going to be
productive for the society or not
whether they're a potential threat or
not the problem is nobody knows concrete
answers there wouldn't be definitive
answers but no one knows concrete
answers and for that we need to study
the situation better
so take more time and his angle Americal
going to go down in history is the
Chancellor of deportation or the
welcoming Chancellor depends is from
what perspective you look at it as I
said back son if you compare the facts
and of course not but if you come paired
with her on welcoming away in 2015 now
you know people like cousin would have a
different opinion I would have a
different opinion of course mmm-hmm same
question Chancellor of deportation the
hard-hearted Chancellor or the welcoming
Chancellor I think what differentiator
from from her colleagues in Europe for
example on the western general is that
she had opened once the French and I
think this is something which will
remain in in the minds mmm welcoming or
the unwelcoming angle America a
hard-hearted Chancellor but to the wrong
people whose heart I would towards the
Greeks towards the southern Europeans or
this austerity and so on so as far as
refugees going a concern to go down in
history as the Chancellor who has in so
many things changed her course so many
times that no one really knew what her
heart was all about quite frankly
mmm-hmm one final question I'm
interested I just like to talk about
Donald Trump because the European said
yeah get him in here yeah the the
Europeans tend to be so sort of
high-minded when appointing to America
and saying Trump's policies are so a
liberal building walls building fences
ejecting immigrants from the country is
Europe not doing exactly the same thing
by building walls and fences to be
honest Donald Trump to in Europe it
could be a different person but like I
would quote a bonnet to ban who's the
knife connects but he said that it could
be a blessing in disguise for
Afghanistan because he may have better
relations with Russia and Russia could
be a potential spoiler
in Afghanistan so he could actually make
sure that Russia doesn't come and spoil
it and we will also not have them if you
keep following okay we're gonna leave it
there on that no thanks very much for
joining us if you've I hope we've given
you plenty of food for thought and if
you've enjoyed the program as much as I
have to come back to quadriga
next week until then bye bye
[Music]